hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the women's world team
championship it will be a refreshing
update upgrading quality after that game
that I played in the previous video it
is a 13 year old video Master Alice Lee
versus a grand master Bella cotanashvili
in this United States versus Georgia now
uh Bella cotton actually was a world
champion she in 2004 she won under 16 uh
Women's World Championship uh that was
uh even before Alice Lee was born so a
very interesting match up here and even
though Alice is currently a feeding
Master she plays board one and ahead of
other players uh that are even
International Masters and women
Grandmaster so let's check out what
happened in this game and why you guys
requested it so Alice has the white
pieces and she opens with Knight to F3
here she goes for the reti opening we
have D5 by Bella D4 Knight to F6 C4 and
E6 so the Queen's Gambit declined Knight
to C3 and Knight beat the D7 so in the
barman variation we have C captures on
D5 uh e captures and now uh most popular
Bishop to G5 and Bishop to F4 but here
we have the immediate Queen to C2
wirelessly uh well that puts more
pressure on e4 and the sort of eyes that
C7 Pawn maybe there are some tricky
lines where you could go after it so C6
is the most common move here but we have
Bishop to B4 now just spinning the
Knight and now Bishop to G5 we have Pawn
to H6 uh and Bella accepts the challenge
he will advance the Pawns in front of
her King side Bishop to G3 and now 94
attacks the bishop and puts more
pressure on the Knight on C3 so Knight
to D2 We have Knight characters and G3 H
captors and now Knight to B6 and
obviously yeah we will see a queen side
Castle so Pawn to A3 Bishop to E7 and
now there is a game where Ponte E4 was
played uh last year in uh in uh a fairly
strong tournament and here we have Queen
side castles which is the top move
recommended by the engine and it is now
as of move 13 mean that we have a
completely new game so okay Bishop to E6
continuing development and now uh the
immediate Pawn the E for not going for
King to B1 as one might expect but
rather Pawn to E4 and the reason why
King to B1 wasn't necessary is because
Bella cannot just play Pawn to C5 here
it seems like an automatic the queen is
on C2 the king is on C1 so of course you
want to play C5 but here it would be uh
it would be very bad the problem is
after d captures and Bishop captures you
will play e captures on D5 and after
Bishop captures Knight captures let's
say and queen captures there's this very
nasty Knight stay E4 move and now your
queen is hanging your Bishop is hanging
Knight to F6 check is being threatened
uh you just don't have time to do
anything here with black and you're just
gonna lose a piece here so there's no
way no no way to actually avoid that so
instead after E4 we have C6 and now Pawn
to E5 okay grabbing more space here
Queen to D7 preparing the castle Queen
side and Bishop to D3 now also by
playing Queen to D7 she had ideas so
maybe bishop to F5 so Bishop to D3 makes
sense uh Castle's Queen side and now
Pawn to F4 now of course you want to get
that pawn to F5 and move in so G
captures G captures and Bishop to G4 and
not allowing the bishop to be trapped
and moving at which Tempo so rook dte1
and king the B8 of course uh you do not
want your king and queen on the same
light diagonal with the White Queen and
Bishop uh well uh having some nasty
ideas for the future and now Knights the
B3 again not worried about King to B1
sugar just goes Knight to B3 now is
ready to put pressure on the C5 square
and also you're just waiting to play F5
F6 so here we have Ponte H5 uh Knight to
D1 now going for Knight to E3 and here
you should stop it with Knight to C4
as it's a it's a very nice square and of
course you're never expecting Bishop
captures on C4 because that's just weird
uh UK you give up one Pawn but then
black just Black's position completely
uh recovers what you will want to do is
just go Knight E3 you trade here let's
say characters captures and then Rook C8
you prepare Pawn to C5 and so on however
here Bishop captures and D1 was played
Queen captures on D1 now putting
pressure on the H5 Pawn so Pawn to H4
and now Pawn to F5 and now okay uh where
is this bishop going uh do you want to
throw in a bishop to G5 check or do you
want to keep the bishop there to guard
the the C5 Square uh Rook D to G8 was
played in the game now preparing uh to
capture on G2 but also maybe Rook to G3
in some ideas uh and queen to F3 and
here
although Rook the G3 does seem like an
idea it would be a terrible blunder
because if you play Rook the G3 here
Alice could just capture it Queen
captures and after Pawn captures Rook
captures the black is just dead lost
here after a king to C7 you can play F6
you attack the bishop only Square for
the bishop is the d8 square now Knight
to C5 attacks the queen and once the
queen moves somewhere doesn't really
matter where now you just break through
E6 and after let's you can even win a
pawn with track let's say queen captures
on F6 e captures an F7 and that's it if
you capture the Rogue then just Rook to
d8 it will uh support the promotion of
the F Pawn and if you capture the pawn
then just Knight E6 check blunders the
bishop doesn't blunder the bishop but
you have to give up something let's say
you go here now Knight captures attacks
the queen and that's pretty much it let
the queen G7 that you attack the queen
and now you resign because you either
give up the queen or Rook to E6 will be
checkmate
uh so after Queen to F3 Knight the A4
was played by Bella and now comes Pawn
to F6 okay you attack the bishop Bishop
to f8 and now Bishop to F5 just winning
more more uh squares more space between
the d8 and now Rook the H3 a stopping
Rook to G3 altogether uh A6 and now King
to B1 uh before uh starting the attack
we have C5 D captures on C5 Knight
captures with Knight captures and Bishop
captures and now okay uh Bella finally
played C5 she opened up the position he
had she has the pass deep on uh but now
uh other problems uh reveal themselves
Rook the C1 uh comes with Tempo and you
can't really move the bishop because
Rook the C8 check would win the queen
and you would very happily give up the
rook and the bishop for the queen so you
have to defend between the B6 but now
you lose the D Pawn so Queen captures on
D5 uh now again with pressure on the
bishop Bishop E3 attacks The Rook here
and now just Rook the C3 again
threatening to in the bishop so you
don't have time to do anything about the
F7 Pawn hanging Rook the d8 attacks the
queen queen captures an F7 and now
Bishop to D4 but it's not a problem
Queen B3 or Rook B3 defended by the
queen here and you have to defend
against Checkmate and B7 so here Queen
to C6 and now Rook to B4 uh and what you
play here well it really doesn't matter
there's no move that saves you here Rook
h2f8 was played but this only allows for
an elegant finish and that is a rook
captures on D4 giving up the queen Rook
captures on F7 and The Rook captures and
the eight with check with King to A7 and
now Pawn to E6 there's no way to stop
all the pawns if you capture on F6 then
just spawn to E7 you cannot stop
promotion you have to capture here and
then after E8 queen you are just down a
full Rook there's no way of course uh
you know you can play this so after E6
Queen to c7u you have to somehow figure
out a way on how to prevent the the
pawns from queening he captures an F7 a
queen capture serokan d8 and now uh Bush
up the C2 it's uh not merely a matter of
keeping one of the pawns alive and then
waiting for the Rook to come of course
um at E8 to allowed the promotion of the
F Pawn so Bishop to C2 we have Queen to
f8 you cannot capture if you capture
then then just Rook F3 attacks the queen
next move your queen uh so after Bishop
to C2 Queen to f8 was played now Bishop
to B3 the pawn is now nicely defended
and there is really nothing you can do
here Queen to D6 was played but now King
A2 not allowing for any tricky checks uh
and pawn to A5 you know that now uh the
the there's a no stopping at The Rook so
you might as well try some tricky moves
here Rook to D3 even offering a rook for
the promotion of the F Pawn Queen back
to f8 and now Pawn to a for stopping
Ponte A4 by uh by Bella so upon the B5
uh this is Now Now or Never Rook to D7
checking the B6 and now Rook to E7 now
there's no defense against rookie 8B
captures on A4 was played but even a
nice calm Bishop to E6 before finishing
the game H3 G captures an H3 Queen to H6
and now Rook to E8 the the the DF Pawn
is coming Ponta A3 and now just f8 Queen
and it was in this position and move 51
uh did Bella cotonous really resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here the problem is of course you
are getting checkmated and even if you
do something like this you threaten
Checkmate it's still very easy just Rook
V8 checking A7 now even Checkmate is
being defended and you can take your
time to just Checkmate the black king
there's nothing you can do here
uh Queen B7 will be made let's say if
Queen G2 defending then just Queen C7
check King A6 and Bishop to C4 I will
end the game I know how you guys like it
when I finish the game so this is one
way to finish the game but he actually
of course did not wait for this after
the promotion of the F Pawn uh she
resigned the game here so a brilliant
game by uh affiliate Master a 13 year
old female Master Alice Lee against a
very very strong Grandmaster Bella
cotton ashwilli and even though Alice
defeated Abella on board one uh her team
still lost the match so you know tough
for the team but great stuff for young
Alice uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it thank you for
recommending such a such a very nice
game I really enjoyed it myself I would
like to thank Bonbon soul and baby boo
girls niches festival.org.gg Amanda
Oliver the most beautiful girl in the
world Duncan weinkle and Eggbert yeah
Ian sheerhorn for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing coverage of well all the
events that are currently happening and
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions as usual so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day